else is what we did on friday do you
remember that actually i'll take that
back
we reviewed solving true equations
proving trig identities and then we
introduced
t results so just in case you're a
little bit um fuzzy on it or you weren't
physically present okay the idea was
we introduce um this tan
of theta on two or x on two or any n two
really
we call it t and we use that kind of
like a common denominator
for all our regular trig functions okay
so just like i think the analogy i gave
was if you added
two fractions like this okay in order to
get them to talk to each other interact
you need a common denominator namely in
this case a twelfth
right so this will be three twelves this
will be two and then you can get your
answer
right so this is kind of like our common
denominator for sun causing tan
right now i just sort of remind me i
think i derived the results but we
didn't really take it anywhere
i just showed you what they were i'm not
going to go into the proof because you
can go back
on the video and do it yourself but what
are the results
going from 10 you start with tandem yeah
yeah it's also meant to be fine
that's a life yeah i'm doing well today
that's what i get for skipping lines i'm
working okay
now you start from here and you say well
okay what will your other
identities be think about your double
angle okay so here's where i'm gonna
display this so regular tan theta
or x's or alphas it doesn't matter what
you use okay
is going to be in terms of this but
double angle right so regular double
angle is
two times that ten ratio but we just
shorthand
call it t on one minus t
squared okay just ringing bells so
you're used to reading this as tan
2x is 2 10x minus 1
on 1 minus 10 squared x okay all i've
done is just rephrase it a little bit
now from there we use the same idea and
we said sine
is going to be 1 minus t squared
sorry i want 2t on 1 plus t
squared and cos
is one minus one plus
happy with that remember that yes now i
stopped sort of actually saying how can
you use this
hopefully my introduction to the lesson
looking at equation equations and
looking at identities
gave you a bit of a clue as to okay well
how can you actually use it
so here's my first example the other one
i'll cover today i gave you tons of work
last lesson so i'm gonna
after i finish with that um let you get
on with it
how we do this normally let's think
about how we do normal
tan 2x cot x actually i'll just start
with the left hand side
if we were to treat this just like a
normal identity right i think generally
we think about what identities we can
use we bring things down to the basic
you know sines and cosines and then you
just
bash it out from there okay so let's
give this a go the first thing i see
that's easy to break apart is that tan
2x
okay so just like before use your double
angle formula so up on the top
that's going to be 2 tan x that cod x i
could break it apart but i'm going to
leave it
as you'll see why in a second cut x
on 1 minus 10 squared
okay so far so good now the reason why i
left the cot
in its place is because
tan are reciprocals so these two are
just going to cancel out right
so i'm going to get 2 on now i might as
well deal with the
denominator as well that tan squared is
sine squared on cos squared
right
now thinking about where i'm heading
right where my right hand side is what
my goal
is i'm going to have to uh undo my
double angle formula in a second
okay so i'm having think about how i can
reshape this
so that i'll end up with a a 2x here
again
because i've brought everything down to
single x's so i've got to go back
right so where my brain goes is
multiply everything through by cos
squared okay now maybe you're like
as i do that hopefully you'll see why
but i know to do that because i've done
questions like this you know
hundreds and thousands of times but it
might not be so obvious to you
okay so what will i do multiply through
by cos squared
this is going to become cos squared and
this is going to become
sine squared ah now hopefully you can
recognize this
i've got the this is cos2x that's the
sec 2x that i'm after
does that make sense but again that
might not be so obvious until you
you sort of gone around in a few circles
for a while okay now
keep that in mind what do i do with the
top
now a few different ways to think about
it here i think is the most
obvious way i'm going to take those two
cos squares and
pull them apart so cos squared x
plus cos squared x okay and on the
bottom here i've got my cos
2x like i said before now why did i
bother saying
2 cos squared x is cos squared plus cos
squared because
just in my brain it makes a little more
obvious that
one cos squared i can sub that out for
1 minus sine squared remember that
that's the pythagorean
so cos squared on the top
plus 1 minus sine squared you see where
i'm going
here all on cos two x now even though
they're separated by a plus one
maybe i'll just move that plus one along
the end to make it a little more obvious
now on the top i've got my color squared
minus sine squared so again
cos 2x minus 1.
okay now i'm basically there okay that
numerator i can just break it apart
cos 2x on cos 2x is 1 1 on cos 2x is
sec 2x and i'm hoping that was plus one
okay oh sorry thanks
great okay so you're happy with that
now uh you might have taken maybe one or
two more lines extra to do that
because some of these steps for instance
at this point here i was like
bingo i exactly know where to go because
i've done questions like this
and because i have my eyes on the prize
i know exactly where i'm headed
okay but it might have taken you a
little longer to get there
also you double angle up here and here
that's a bit weird uh maybe you saw
this identity a little more obviously a
little more straightforward it didn't
jump out at me
i had to break it apart to see it you
know that kind of thing
but this is kind of emblematic of how
when you get a trig identity like this
parts of it i just sort of leaps of
conceptual leaps they're like well if
you see it you see it and if you don't
you just kind of scratch your head for a
little while right
the tea results are about taking that
guesswork out okay
so this is how we would do it using our
regular identities
how would we do it with t results well
take your um your equation here have a
look at it and the first thing you do is
think about
what kind of substitution should i make
okay now
i said right at the beginning that we
usually say this
tan and x on two right so
good good try it's a half angle result
right and you can see here i don't have
any half angles what i've got is double
angles
instead okay so what i'm going to use is
i'm going to start off by saying
let t equal
just a single tan x no no half angle
okay
now what that's going to do is it's
going to double all of my angles
right it's going to double all of them
so therefore 10
sorry tan 2x
this is just my regular old double angle
formula this is
2t on 1 minus t
squared okay can you see where i get
that from it's just the double x
now the next thing i think about is look
at the identity both sides okay look at
all the pieces that i've got left
all you need to do is write each one in
terms of the t formula okay
so 10 to x i've already got that one
tick
i've got to get cot x and i've got to
get sec
2x all right let's think about cot
that's an easy one
cot's the reciprocal of tan right so
therefore
plot x is just one on t
right make sense sec 2x sec
is one over cos so let's just think
about cos first
close to x will be how good are you with
your
with your memory what's the uh what's
the t result
for cos
one minus c squared from the top
one more plus on the bottom okay i know
these are this is the
the extra work that t results gets but
hopefully it will be justified in a
second
now what i want is not caused by sex so
i just flip it upside down
okay now i've got all my pieces
one two three now pay attention here for
a second
um last lesson when we talked about
solving trig identities sorry proving
trig identities like this
we said you've got to go from one side
to another
you you can't sort of stop at some
middle point okay
so can we meet in the library exception
the exception to the rule is t results
and you'll see why
in a second okay so with t results you
can go to west penn hills
okay and those of you who wait here
you'll be like
okay all right so here's what i'm gonna
do i've got all of my substitutions
ready it's sort of like a
i think of this part like on a cooking
show right and like jamie always there
and suddenly everything is all
pre-cut and balls and he just chucks it
in like no wonder he could do 15-minute
meals anyway
so here's your pre-set up okay it's a
total liar i tried 30 minute meals once
and it took me like
one and a half hours i've got them all
set up take one side
evaluate and simplify so let's do this
let's do the left hand side tan 2x
cod x that's going to be this one 2t on
1 minus t squared
times 1 over t
that's the two pieces so what can you do
to that not much
those t's cancel and that's where you
finish that's as simple as it gets
right so you stop then you look at the
other side
that's 1 plus sec 2x okay so
1 plus that one over that one
okay so that's just a fraction you add
them together so 1 minus t squared plus
1
plus t squared on one minus two squared
t squared's cancel
and then you go home and laugh at the
people who still have to do this okay so
that's it
that's it now when you look at it like
next to each other okay they do look
about the same
okay you do have to do this pre-set up
before you actually get into your proof
but for certain kinds of identities this
is so much easier like look at this
not only is it less lines but there are
easy lines
right you don't even have to you almost
don't have to think because you guys
have been doing this for years now
whereas this
is sort of still harder even for after
doing this for like you know two three
years
people can still be quite poor at this
because they don't see the conceptual
leaps
between different lines and they're just
like i don't know okay
so there's just one example on the sheet
that i gave you
which looks like this so i know i think
you the knockout people i think got it
because i think ivy
keeps it up for everyone because he's
awesome um anyone else who didn't get it
or maybe
misplace yours at home grab it out uh
what you can do is exodus 5c see how it
says prove the following identities okay
you can prove them whichever way you
like i'd actually like you
for some of the later questions to for
example let's do question five
question five a b c d there's four parts
okay i'd like you to do them both ways
i'd like you to solve them both ways
i know that seems like double the work
right but the point
is so you can see sometimes you choose
one
it's a good idea to actually do it the
original way okay sometimes
t results doesn't save you any time
because doing all this it's like
oh there was some simple identity that
just made it come out now
your ability to choose which one you
should which one's faster
it only comes in practice i can't give
you a rule like you always use it with
this kind of problem
you sort of have to practice okay